You’re right in the middle of one of the
hottest summers on record.
The days are filled with bright, scorching
sun and searing heat., and you’ve been laying
around with your air conditioning on full
blast just to try and cool yourself off.
Sadly, it’s not really working, and the
heat is becoming way too much.
But then you remember, there’s this married
couple that lives near you, with no kids,
and they happen to have a swimming pool in
their yard.
Normally they keep to themselves, they’d
never let you use their pool, but they’ve
gone out of town for a few days.
Besides, the heat is killing you, you’re
sure that the neighbors wouldn’t mind if
you just took a quick dip, as long as you
clean up after yourself.
They probably wouldn’t even notice you were
ever there.
Cautiously, you make your way to their house.
It’s an unremarkable place, similar to most
of the other houses in this suburb of New
Mexico.
After checking that there’s nobody else
around, you climb the two-meter high cinder
block wall that stands around the back garden.
As you drop to your feet, sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat, you see
it: the pool, your salvation.
Water never looked so appealing.
Immediately, you step barefoot across the
sun-scorched tiles and sit on the edge, legs
in the water.
It’s cool and refreshing, perfect for a
day as hot as today.
You’re already changed and wearing your
swim trunks, so it doesn’t take long for
you to paddle out to the middle of the pool,
letting that chilled, clean water cool you
off.
As you’re taking a dip, you notice the pool’s
jets turning on automatically.
It’s a little bit odd, but you shrug it
off.
That couple clearly shelled out for a pool
with a lot of fancy bells and whistles.
But extra features aren’t why you’re here,
you came because if you didn’t, then you
could have melted under all that sunlight.
Floating on the surface of the water, you
relax with your arms behind your head and
close your eyes.
You don’t have time to realize that coming
here was a mistake.
Instead, you start to feel relaxed.
So calm, so tranquil.
You’re one with the water around you now.
It’s almost as though you could just disappear…
So, you do.
The police never find any trace of you, everyone
else simply writes it off as a random disappearance.
There’s not even so much as a scrap of your
body left in the pool, just the clear, clean
water.
Why?
Because the swimming pool you decided to take
a cooling dip in wasn’t an ordinary pool.
It was SCP-242.
But don’t worry, you won’t be the last
to make that costly mistake.
What you didn’t know is that the “married
couple” who live in that house are secretly
a pair of SCP Foundation doctors.
The house isn’t even theirs, the Foundation
procured it after the former owner, a retired
out-of-state landlord, strangely vanished.
He had been struggling to find anyone to rent
the place, so eventually decided to give up
on the property game and move in there himself.
After three days, he was never seen again.
Now, that house has only one rule that must
be followed above all else: do not swim in
the pool.
SCP-242 is, at least to the untrained eye,
just an average swimming pool.
A decent nine meters in length, four and a
half wide, and it holds around 53,000 liters
of sterile pool water.
Like we mentioned before, it’s even got
some nifty features like water jets, a dual
waterfall, and a built-in vacuum unit for
sucking out any impurities.
And we mean any impurities.
You see, SCP-242 does go by another name:
the Self Cleaning Swimming Pool.
And while that might not sound as foreboding
or dramatic as “The Scarlet King” or “The
Wendigo Skull” or “The Horrifying Nasty-Dude
of Ultimate Badness” - okay, we made that
last one up - we can assure you that you don’t
ever want to suffer the fate of taking a swim
in this pool.
There was an incident a while ago, recorded
by the Foundation through a secret hidden
camera.
The house where SCP-242 can be found had been
left vacant for a time, and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage of
the empty swimming pool.
This time it was a couple, a man and a woman
in their early twenties.
They climbed up the back wall, undressed,
and even stole a couple of plastic inflatable
rafts from a shed in the house’s backyard.
The water jets switched themselves on, startling
the girl, but her boyfriend told her not to
worry, the filter to clean the pool was probably
just on an automatic timer, right?
Surely it wouldn’t have been anything to
worry about.
After swimming around together for about twenty
four minutes, the couple both agreed that
the water felt warm, tingly even.
Both of them climbed onto their rafts, eventually
falling asleep while still holding each other’s
hands.
But, almost half an hour after the jets had
started, something caused the two rafts to
burst.
The couple awoke, startled by the loud pop
of the splitting inflatables and being plunged
back into the water.
The pool around them immediately began frothing
violently, deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed in
fear and agony.
Both of them tried to desperately swim to
the edge, hoping to leave the pool and get
to safety.
But unfortunately, that plan didn’t work.
Before they could reach the edge, the man
and the woman were pulled under the surface
of the raging water, their limbs thrashing
as they still tried in vain to escape.
Eventually, they vanished under the crimson,
bloody water.
The frothing slowly began to calm, and the
red in the pool dissipated, once again becoming
clear after forty-eight seconds.
The couple were never seen again, and a cover
story was leaked to the press by the SCP Foundation
two weeks after they went missing.
According to them, the pair had eloped together
somewhere in Mexico.
If only, that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them.
So, this swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties, that much is obvious.
But what exactly are those properties, how
exactly does SCP-242 work?
Is it an interdimensional gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if they
spend too long swimming in it?
Or is the swimming pool itself a sentient,
carnivorous creature that lures humans in
only to devour them?
Maybe the water is teeming with invisible,
flesh-eating piranhas that can strip the meat
from a bone in a matter of seconds.
Well, good guesses all around but actually,
it’s none of these.
It’s unclear what causes the pool’s anomalous
effects, it could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SCP-242.
Or maybe it’s down to the exact shape and
measurements of the pool itself.
It could even be a combination of both.
But whatever the cause, the result is always
the same.
When any object, substance, or even living
organism is placed in SCP-242, it will be
entirely rewritten on a molecular level.
The genetic and atomic structure will fall
apart, and the subject will be transmuted
into sterile water.
In fact, not just clean water, but water that
remains sterile even when removed from the
pool.
If you took a cup of SCP-242’s water and
mixed something like food coloring into it,
the food coloring would not be absorbed into
the water, instead staying as one non-miscible
bubble.
This process doesn’t happen instantly though,
it can vary depending on how contaminated
or complex the substance placed in SCP-242
is.
For example, water sampled from a nearby river
was sterilized and purified by the pool in
about seven minutes.
A sample of stagnant pond water, riddled with
various diseases and germs, took eleven minutes
longer.
What about fifty thousand liters of coal tar?
Well, that one took a little longer, twelve
long days to be exact, but was still turned
into pure, sterile water.
And as for a living human being?
Maybe ask that couple that took a dip in the
Self Cleaning Pool.
The Foundation is naturally fascinated with
the pool, and after extensive examination,
they have determined that SCP-242 doesn’t
seem to have been intentionally designed for
the specific anomalous function it performs.
The components of SCP-242 beyond the pool
itself; the filter, the vacuum, the pipes,
none of these parts nor anything about the
swimming pool’s design appear to be responsible
for disintegrating matter until only water
remains.
You might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in SCP-242,
the water jets and waterfall features switched
themselves on automatically, before the pair’s
grim demise.
Somehow, these features are able to activate
without the need for electricity, as disconnecting
the pool from a power source will not stop
the jets and waterfall from coming on once
a non-water substance is placed into SCP-242.
The same goes for the pool vacuum, which apparently
cannot be jammed or malfunction.
Even when the bottom of the pool is awash
with viscous liquids like that coal tar, the
vacuum will continue to operate as normal,
scrubbing away at the floor of SCP-242.
The one part of the Self Cleaning Pool that
doesn’t work as you would expect is the
water filtration system.
There is never any water being cycled into
the pool, nor out of it.
As a matter of fact, the pipes connected to
the filtration system have all been removed.
Then again, who needs a filtration system
when your backyard swimming pool can just
spontaneously reduce anything to clean water?
But that raises another frightening thought:
Everything that the pool has ever taken and
converted is still in there - animals, objects,
people - just swimming around you.
Perhaps, if they could still think, they’d
scream and shout and tell you to get away.
To run while you still can.
But the second your skin touches the water,
you’re destined to be with them.
Forever and ever and ever.
It’s enough to send a liquid chill down
your spine.
Okay, so if it’s not the actual physical
pool that causes these anomalous effects,
that must mean it’s something in the water,
right?
Perhaps some microscopic, flesh-devouring
microbe, or some ancient curse that was placed
on the water before it was used to fill the
pool?
Surely, if you took a cup of the water out
of SCP-242, it would still break down structures
on a molecular level, leaving only more sterile
water.
Well, the researchers working at the SCP Foundation
thought much the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact properties
of SCP-242’s water.
One test involved submerging two D Class test
subjects, each wearing an atmospheric dive
suit, into SCP-242.
The goal was to determine if it was safe to
consume the water from SCP-242 while both
inside and outside of the pool.
Test Subject A was lowered into the water
and instructed to drink from a metal straw
by their mouth.
The eyepieces of their goggles were blacked
out, so they couldn’t see what they were
drinking from.
Subject B filled a barrel with the same water
from SCP-242, and then was made to put on
an atmospheric dive suit, but instructed to
stay out of the pool.
Test Subject A was told to drink directly
from the pool, remarking that the water was
warm, and had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste, but was otherwise normal.
Then, Test Subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel.
Apparently, it was cool, and tasted of…
well, nothing, just like water usually does.
After a moment more of drink, Subject A began
belching, finding they had uncontrollable
gas.
The water had begun to feel warmer, stinging
the subject’s mouth while, for Subject B,
the water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing.
The Foundation doctors overseeing the experiment
instructed Test Subject A to keep drinking,
which they did until it felt even hotter to
the taste.
One of the D Class’s fillings even fell
out, and eventually, the structural integrity
of Subject A’s dive suit failed, presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP-242.
After a few muffled screams and gurgling noises,
Test Subject A wasn’t heard from again,
and we can all probably guess why.
As for Subject B, they kept drinking from
the barrel, suffering no adverse effects,
even after seventeen long hours.
There were no noticeable psychological or
physical changes, even their urine showed
no traces of abnormality.
The water from SCP-242 left in the barrel
evaporated as normal, leaving behind no residue
or any indicator as to why taking the water
out of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool.
Perhaps the moral of the story is to just
be careful where you choose to take a swim,
otherwise, it could be your last.
Now go check out “SCP-5545 - Mysterious
Tunnels in Antarctica - ABNORMALITY” and
“SCP-1981 - Ronald Reagan Cut Up While Talking
& SCP-095” for more freaky and fascinating
Safe-Class SCPs!